okay people sit your asses down and shut
your pie-holes
I've got places that go and more
important people than you to see because
I happen to be a scientist and we
scientists have a tendency to be very
busy and important people if you're out
there in the folding chairs that means
you're the new guys bottom of the totem
pole but it also means you passed the
entrance exams
welcome to the SPC from this moment
onward your job
is very very simple you are going to
punch sharks in the face you will punch
sharks when not punching sharks you will
be planning on punching sharks you will
be developing new ways to punch sharks
you will read about punching sharks you
will write about punching sharks you
will study punching sharks you will
dream about punching sharks you will
jump the shark you will collect and
contain paranormal objects and then use
them to beat up sharks punching sharks
is your life you may be asking yourself
how am I to punch these sharks with your
fists and you may ask yourself I'm
unsure of what to do go see an alchemist
and you may say to yourself self my
teeth have become shark like in the
sense that they've all turned in sharks
good now start punching them it's an
important job mark my words there are
people out there many people who just
don't understand why they don't realize
how important our job is you will be
challenged you will be mocked you will
be insulted but you cannot lose sight of
the goal your fist in a shark's face
several years ago a former employee
asked me why do we punch sharks
you know what I said to him I said sir
do you hate science
are you a science hating shark hugger do
you approve of the non science shark
agenda
he said no he wasn't but I punched him
in the face anyway because he was
clearly a closeted shark because that is
what we [ __ ] do at the SPCA when you
walk him in here there was a copy of Sun
Tzu's the art of punching sharks on your
chair you are all to have that read by
the time you report in tomorrow morning
now get out of here those sharks are
gonna punch themselves because they
don't have hands